all right so stop sing and build new
Earth so here you can see there's a
bunch of Instagram stories this is
probably a format that I'm going to
follow quite a bit moving forward where
there's a posting of the previous days
Instagram
stories and then there's a streaming
that the net following day that breaks
down and further uh amplifies and
excites and inspires
and just cuts through simping and
inspires action for building the new
world so here um there's just a sharing
that there were five new reels that were
posted from that video about stop sing
and build new Earth which is an awesome
video check it out if you haven't yet
and then that the library is currently
being ported over to rumble also just to
create that that further diversification
uh because of freedom of
speech so here you know this is this
this video is about how rap hits with
the god mode that spiritual [__] can't
handle you know you see there's leaders
and there's followers but I'd rather be
a dick than a swallower you know so that
one
hits where um
like rap hits a certain way that
inspires the god mode activation within
there's no limits or contractions that's
why rappers and hip-hop artists that's
why they can so easily
just go hard on themselves and about
their uniqueness and their gifts and
their message and all that stuff there's
no contractions or bounds or limits they
just go go and it's beautiful because a
spiritual [__] is in a straight jacket
and it can't handle it
uh uh
Economist uh peasant dude peasant
straight up peasant dude the world
economic for Global Elite are going to
eat that up like cake you'll have the
spiritual [__] meditating on cushions
eating cockroaches and getting provided
rations with the centralized Bank
digital currencies while the God mode
Warriors that are Act AC at by
self-realization and that are activated
by building the new world are going to
go out building the basic needs
infrastructures of the new
generation and of and of just slaying
The Matrix
tentacles so here's another one
on there was a comment on on Tik Tok
about um on the on the Reel that was
posted about surrender the whole body A
New Earth and the question was I'm
trying to learn do you have any book
recommendations and this is a typical
thing is to ask about book
recommendations and whatnot and there's
a way to sort of cut through what is
this journey that takes eons to
surrender one's small self to the big
self and the selfless gifts so that's
why there's a reflection back that's
really sharp and that just cuts through
the apparent eons of Journey to just get
right into it
uh cleanly so that's why best for the
self to get out of the way for the
capital S self which is everything the
self has the codes of the selfless gifts
because when one is the capital S self
there is no tendency to want to do
action there's no more doing of action
that is related to the small s self
which is unworthiness and seeking
validation and trying to get for
itself and the thing looking out the
eyes is nothing being every everything
including the body this is usually
enough to see through selfing so meaning
the thing when the thing that's looking
out the eyes is itself nothing
everything when that's the case then it
can be integrated into the warrior of
the character it can be integrated into
building new Earth from that
place this was also from from a friend
that was saying uh where did you get it
that I was free I'm still lost in my
dream 90% of the time I'm thinking that
y'all are going to have to go on without
this one I'm too committed to my
nightmare so and there's just the reply
of Ragnar from Vikings
because all that's all that that's all
that you can do especially because the
the conversation with this one it's it's
like they're they're digging their heels
in their own dream so if you're if
you're if you're being reflected back
that no I'm digging my heels in my dream
and that I refuse to to come out you
know you can't do anything I mean Ragnar
you can grab them by the testicle slap
them in the face and tell them get the
[__] on the battlefield you [__] you can
do
that but then there might be all kinds
of resentments and all kinds of things
and there's just there's got to be an
activation and a constitutionalization
within that body itself that's ready to
go to war for New Earth that's ready to
completely give up its
dream and that's up to the military
General's discernment also is to see
who's actually activated like that
that's willing to come on the
battlefield and lock arms as brothers
and sisters for the new
world so started going more ham here
coming at the throats of the sing beta
cucks I swear I'm going to kill every
single sing beta cck Alive by dragging
them by their testicles from behind
their computer computer watching only
fans to shoving their face in the dirt
of the battlefield for New
Earth Allan has been anointed new king
of the manosphere here your highness you
drop
this any man who took the vaccine and
sucked the [__] of Big Daddy gov instead
of rebelling resisting and critical
thinking deserves to be annihilated in
those WF Matrix prisons being built so
here's the
thing if there's simping that's
happening it is the most important
program to dislodge is sing of any sort
I don't give a [__] what you're sing to
I don't care if you're simping to uh
only fans or if you're sing to gurus or
if you're sing to a daddy government or
if you're sing to seeking validation
from your own mom and dad um I don't
care who the [__] you're sing to that's
all got to be absolutely obliterated if
you don't obliterate that beta cuck sing
[__] and if you don't [__] get
going and get [__] working out taking
good care of the of the body of getting
ignited for the new world of ceasing all
of those stupid programs then you'll be
you'll just take the Jabs you'll take
the Jabs you'll say yes daddy government
jab me jab me Daddy jab me jab me
Daddy and all critical thinking will be
gone cuz those programs will be running
the show and then what what what we're
what we're seeing is we're seeing these
these the the most it's crazy because
it's the the the prisoners themselves
are the ones that are uh further
solidifying their own jail cells so it's
not even that the WF is the culprit it's
that the programs that are being
propagated are then being are running in
the open space of Mind these programs
are running that are then taking the
body prisoner and turning the body into
a slave to build its own prison in these
cities where there's centralized Bank
digital currencies and where there's
propaganda and oversight and all kinds
of limits on the freedom and sovereignty
of the human
spirit so [__] all that and godamn build
the new Sovereign infrastructures before
I slap you awake
[__] this is also lovely is you're only
ever talking to a light hologram so be
Fearless so you know when you see a
video that pops up online and it's like
the whatever the the uh European Union's
head of Finance or whatever and it's
like we're digitizing the Euro and now
we're going to be overseeing all
transactions and we're going to be the
ones that get to dictate what you can
and can't do with your money basically
they're going to be the ones that set
the limits on your freedom when you see
that video that's a light hologram so be
[__] fearless and godamn punch punch
those Matrix tentacles fearlessly punch
them same thing when someone replies to
you in person or online or wherever
someone replies to you and they're like
oh I'm a beta cck I like getting the
jobs or I believe in daddy government or
whatever [__] Roar at them
fearlessly a
ah Roar at them fearlessly for New Earth
Roar at them Roar at them because it's
just a light hologram it's just a light
hologram that's where this fearlessness
can come from that's why you can feel
like you're wielding these
swords feel like you're wielding those
swords that have etched on them new
Earth or bust you know I'm going to to
die on this [__] sword of new
Earth so this is more uh screenshots of
conversations that I'm having with
different people so six Jabs later
completely infertile DNA corrupted GI
destroyed lethargic eating poisonous
foods beep booping beep beep beep
booping beep beep beep
beep beep boop boop boop boop like
Matrix cattle Matrix cattle beep beep
Boop
Bo
[Music]
Boop Matrix cattle
beepop Matrix
cattle
so that program that chips inserted and
now it's ironic because it's basically
the Roman circus again divide and
conquer wild totality Arian tiptoe
siphon the wealth out of both arguing
parties slowly while they're distracted
and it's [__] obvious the United
States government got ungodly bloated
and then um there's just been so much
[__] corruption and the this this
this ridiculous bipartisan gridlock in
argument and hatred of the other and
then meanwhile Global elitists come and
use the United States government as a
piggy bank to just
siphon out as much money from the poor
and middle class as possible
exacerbating wealth inequality uh
inflating the 0.1% inflating their the
richness meanwhile poor and middle class
people eat dog [__] don't own their own
homes don't uh own their own time and so
it's it is the [__] Matrix
enslavement and so we are to exit and
build we are to exit and build the new
and we are to [__] obliterate all of
the godamn uh Matrix tentacles that are
saturating into our
spirits and stop allowing your body to
get this dude stop allowing your body
think about it man a jab is exactly like
you're allowing Big Daddy to stab you
basically and then the funny thing is
you allow Big Daddy to stab you and then
you come back again and say big Daddy
will you stab me again please just stab
me again please Big Daddy D so you see
what you're doing when you agree to that
you're you're you're you're going to
where the Matrix is testing you it's
testing you to see if you're going to
let it [__] you with its blade that's
what's happening and then what what
what's happening within the body is that
that that DNA that that beautiful
bloodline of the New World Warrior that
is supposed to reproduce and that's
supposed to have an abundance of New
World Warriors and New World artists and
new world
creatives uh and beautiful awake
children is now becoming lethargic the
GI is having issues it's eating the
shitty poisonous foods
and the programs that are running it's
all about the obso of all of those
[__]
programs waking up the beep
boopers so all of it is obvious to
anyone trained in the dark arts it has
been blatantly obvious since the US gov
got bloated humans are movable cattle
for Global Elites running satanic
programs revealing in plain sight their
ruling Playbook the fappers are stuck in
circles declining the blatantly obvious
duality of
War asleep in patterns seeking for a
sword to strike and destroy the as
sleepness to ignite the warrior within
to die into the Transcendent game and
then there's a picture of Collie
chopping off heads with GG or good game
below
that so anyone trained in the dark arts
can see the ruling Elites Playbook right
it's it's transparent it has to be
transparent that's part of the game part
of the game is for it to be laid out as
transparent because then the karmic
consequences are not there so what's
happening is it's being laid out and
then knowingly and willingly you see it
being laid out and you still agree to it
you watch the government saying we're
going to have centralized Bank digital
currencies [__] we're going to have
them we're going to have them you're
watching endless videos about
centralized Bank digital currencies and
then the day that they finally come and
lock all of your [__] money into what
they want you to do with it and limit
you with it then you say oh well okay I
guess either you'll join into the
further into the Matrix prisons or
you'll will finally get catalyzed hard
enough to get liberated and build the
new world and so it's you've been warned
you've been warned and it's blatantly
obvious the United States government
back 300 years ago it never 250 years
ago it never had this
intention 250 years ago there was never
the intention for it to go up in
population by an order of magnitude and
for the government to get so bloated and
for the wealth inequality to get so
drastic um um and for um there to be
such a an obliteration of the ethos of
the Constitution and for there to be um
such a a a disregard for the humanness
of uh of the working class there's an
absolute disregard for it there is a
total uh separation that's happened in
the west where um uh instead of the way
that trees and mushrooms exchange
nutrients with each other underground in
Perfect Harmony as nature where humans
can biomimic that it's become complete
separate silos of [__] billionaires
and corporate CEOs and deep State Elites
and all kinds of [__] all kinds of
[__] and all kinds of [__]
hoarding and it's time to call it out
the way it is it's time to build the new
and it's time to uh create the Catalyst
that wake up those uh that wake up those
that are in those positions of wealth in
those silos because they can come on to
the new earth side and create a big
splash um in in that direction
so and the fappers the ones that are
just fapping fap fap fap fap fap on
whatever platforms o only fans are on
[__] social media scrolling or
whatever um fap fap fap fap fap just
lost in the same fapping Loop pretending
like The Duality of this Infinity war is
not real it's just pretending it really
is it's you're just pretending that uh
that you can relax back back into
Oneness and just allow everything to
happen that's bypassing your character's
Divine role in this game your
character's Divine role in this game is
to go out and [__] serve serve for
the new Earth serve your gifts there is
no bypassing there is no spectating you
[__] Spectators are starting to
piss me off you [__] fappers you
[__] fappers back there fap fap fap
fap starting to piss me off I'm coming
for your [__] heads and so the as
sleepness in those patterns is there is
a little pin holes and so if these
catalysts get into those little pin
holes where the program is running there
can be like an explosion that happens of
that program and there can be like a
glitch that happens and then from The
Matrix programming there can be a shift
to the new Earth programming that's what
a lot of this show is this show is
generating those catalysts that get into
those little pin holes of those
contracted programs that then shatter
them out of the Matrix and into building
new
Earth and that ignites the warrior
within to die into the Transcendent game
and that's your GG right
there so it's just too obvious it's so
obvious there this is the truth and
there's no arguing it that there are
trillions of dollars that are being
hoarded by the demon of lack and
separation and Silo rather than being
invested into free energy and basic
needs there's no arguing it you have all
of these archetypes of the solar Punk
decentralized basic needs future of
abundance for all and freedom for all of
humanity and then you have these
trillions of dollars that are being
hoarded by global Elites that are where
they could easily be put into free
energy systems and easily be put into
decentralizing basic needs and abundance
for all but they're not they're not you
have you have and this l list goes on
and on and on and on with people that
have billions and billions and billions
of [__] dollars with a B billions of
dollars and it goes on and on and on and
on the selfishness the greed the
corruption the [__] ego the satanic
programs that are running that prevent
the obliteration of of The Silo of
Separation so there's just no hiding it
anymore and there's no repressing it
anymore it's going to be said exactly
how it is cuz this is exactly how it is
we have everything to build free energy
systems and basic needs infrastructures
and Free People and yet we don't so
let's be [__] real about it and call
it out exactly how it is and Shepherd
the building of that new Earth and
generate these
catalysts and this is great too you know
and if you close your eyes can you see
that nothing Chang at all because here's
the thing nothing ever changes when you
close your eyes you can clearly see that
nothing's really changing and yet at the
same time all of this change is
eternally apparent and it's
[Music]
endless and so that's just the that's
just the nature of the games that God
plays that this Infinity plays is that
nothing changes and yet everything
apparently eternally changes and there's
endless games there's endless ways to
fall asleep and wake up there's endless
ways to go to war with yourself as God
and so here we
are there's a conversation I was having
with a friend you know just literally
just joking around
because when when you do when you just
obliterate all programs and all limits
you're able to Envision crazy [__] like
this 100 foot Giants uner dick so big
that the forcein can stretch out and
cover my whole body from head to toe
maybe we're all got smegma Mak sense
scale invariance cuz literally who is
there to care right there's no one home
who is there to care no one no one just
God just God right so this is just God's
joke no one's here to care and yet all
there is is this an apparent raging [__]
yelling for New Earth just God puppeting
the body for New
Earth and here's another conversation
with another friend just that it's
beyond raw and all channeling it's
beyond all of that it's just the nature
of light
itself and there is a skyus to how it
works an Ain to how it works and just
like there is a
ground like there's an earth to how it
works and the pain of repressing is
worst the pain of repressing is worst
and full send is the the light full send
it [__] full send it
[__] full send it that is the
light full send it full send
it full send it full send it full send
all your unique gifts for New Earth full
send
it so this one may have to rotate the
device a little to see it I would I
didn't come prepared to with for the for
the uh horizontal ones oh um everything
is God this is energy Mastery and more
truth is said less follow weeding out
those that come on ride are on Warfield
living
truest so this is again absolutely
unarguable that everything is God and
this is energy Mastery so your beingness
is in energy Mastery School and so
energy Mastery means when another body
comes up and it's talking about oh my
God you know VX me Daddy Let's get the
jab let's build Let's Help be prisoners
in our Matrix cells your energy Mastery
is at that is your learning there is to
be like n [__] we're going to build the
new Earth [__] all that
[__] byebye and that's that's how you uh
when someone is suffering when someone's
going through some sort of pain when
someone's going through some sort of
transformation your work in energy
Mastery is helping serve them in
whatever they're going through as a
transformation because every time one of
those programs is is obliterated by a
catalyst what's happening is there's a
glitching that's happening and during
that glitching process going towards the
new Earth out of the Matrix towards the
new Earth there's usually the need for
there to be someone there that can uh
relate to that and help and help them
help be a guide until there's enough
energy Mastery built where one feels
Sovereign and can help those that are
making the transformation themselves so
it's actually uh really beautiful that
this is all energy Mastery and that we
can serve those that are going through
their transformations to become New
World Warriors and ignited and the more
that truth is said the less is that that
is that that follows
because what's happening is that those
that are saying truthful Things Are
being
cancelled you can see it with uh Russell
Brand it just happened with it happened
with Andrew Tate um it happened with uh
with even with Donald Trump it happened
Julian
Assange um it's it's happened with so
with so many um of this cancel culture I
mean I even went all the way back to uh
to
Tupac because it's happened with with
all of it you can tell when someone
starts tell saying saying things that
are truth ful what happens is there's
there's a matrix attack which is trying
to get um them imprisoned for something
that didn't happen and that's a
continuous thing it's an obvious
continuous thing it's an obvious trait
of the dark arts it's the way to repress
freeing people and freeing Earth and and
supporting the basic needs it's true
truly truly is and that that that's the
great weeding out that's happening this
is the Great Purge the Great Purge
that's happening is if you're going to
be um a a a matrix zombie or if you
going and then eventually get killed
because AI robots and all that [__] is
taking over
anyway or if you're going to Homestead
and build the new basic needs
infrastructures of the world and say
[__] you to all of that [__] and um
those that come on this ride are on the
Warfield they're living their truest
because they know that this is this is
the only way forward there's no more
sitting back and doing nothing that it's
not going to work anymore there's a
certain time during the spiritual
journey where it makes sense to learn
how to do nothing and feel the Divine
silence and Stillness underneath of
everything but that's a short part of
the journey that's a short part of
grocking what one truly is because then
that must be integrated into the body
into the Warfield itself and go and
[__] fight and die for the new world
this battlefield is a Warrior's wet
dream moving forward retain extreme
sovereignty of the body and stand
unshakable in that word roar like a lion
with new Earth at who speaks highly of
the jab or any Matrix control system
other soldiers will align to your
frequency the programs are fragile and
made of dust homesteading in basic needs
communities is the best bet for the next
Generations as the Matrix deploys more
Control
Systems get exced excited about slaying
all those demonic Matrix tentacles It's
A Warrior's wet dream to be on this
battlefield you see it's the wet dream
of the warrior to be on this battlefield
so get the [__] on the battlefield with
your gifts with your sword building the
new obsoleting the old roaring like a
lion shattering The Matrix Control
Systems all of it's just made of dust
anyway all of it's a light hologram
anyway so swing your [__] sword and
build the godamn new and Homestead
Homestead in the new communities
Homestead in those new
communities The Matrix will have you do
all kinds of things again obvious to
anyone who has studied the dark arts the
propaganda is inserted as programs into
the open space of mind the self is
hijacked by these programs and the body
begins behaving with dishonor selfish
greed unethical separation sing to the
same Machinery that sent the toxic
programs when the hijacker is fearless
LLY annihilated by the open space god
reclaims his channel and puppets the
body the spiritual [__] is one of the
final programs that the hijacker runs to
retain control if you're not just an
empty body fighting for New Earth you're
not done on the path God will
effortlessly Roar this out the body's
mouthpiece when the douche [__]
contractor is done sing in
delusion so again anyone trained in the
dark arts can see how [__] obvious
this is it's so obvious the propaganda
is inserted as programs into the open
space of mind nothing everything there
is only God God Only God is real and so
then this propaganda comes in as these
dust programs that is literally what it
is it's just dust programs the sense of
separation and the sense of self that
lacks that is greedy selfish
dishonorable that is simply a dust
program that is running within the
body so the self gets hijacked by those
programs capital S self and then the
body begins dis behaving with this
dishonor and it begins sing to that same
Machinery that sent the toxic programs
okay so you can see that then the that
dust program that's running it's main
protocol in a way is to worship the very
toxic Machinery that sent the program to
it so when um the propaganda says that
says that government is very good
government you should be okay with the
military-industrial complex you should
be okay with the job you should be okay
with the centralized Bank digital
currencies that's why then that dust
program begins worshiping all of those
things it doesn't even fight or Rebel or
question against those things you see
and then it then further goes and when
it talks to other bodies it promulgates
that same Matrix agenda and
program and then the hijacker is
fearlessly annihilated by the open open
space god reclaims his channel and
puppets the body and
so the spiritual [__] is one of the
final programs that the hijacker runs to
retain control so what's happening is
that when the um when the dust
programmed the dust program gets a
little tiny pinhole it gets a little pin
holes right so those little glitches
that happen so catalysts like this
travel across the ether to The Matrix
zombies and it hits the little pinhole
of light that's that's open for the
Catalyst to come in and then the
Catalyst will has the opportunity to
explode that Matrix program and
so what happens is
that this is typically what's called
like the spiritual journey or the
transformative Journey out of Matrix out
of Separation out of lack out of selfing
out of greed and selfishness and
dishonor and into building new Earth
into non-duality into into spirituality
into love and transformation and
abundance for all and all of those
things
so that's when when when all of these
little hijacker programs including the
spiritual [__] one which is such a
[__] [__] the spiritual [__] one is
such a [__] the spiritual [__] one is
is such a [__] tight straight jacket
it's all of these [__] that
that sit on the goddamn Royal
philosopher chairs with the little
flowers on the side and that have all
their Seekers suck on their testicles
that's the spiritual [__] program and
that has to die that [__]
program has to godamn die and all of
those Seekers and teachers and all of
them need to get on the goddamn
Battlefield and build a new Earth
infrastructure and start [__] hating
The
Matrix that's the duality of the
infinity War it is not [__] sucking a
testicle of a guru for [__] for this
entire Incarnation that is the spiritual
industrial complex in a nutshell is a
Seeker with testicles in its mouth
sucking on the guru's nut sack for its
whole Incarnation that's the spiritual
industrial complex in a
nutshell so that program needs to also
be
obliterated and then the hijackers run
out of control systems and then the open
space of self with a capital S God
effortlessly puppets the body for New
World the mou piece has been liberated
it's been liberated it can just [__]
flow nothing wrong can ever be said and
it can enter into the battlefield like
The Fearless goddamn Warrior it is in
this Infinity War for basic needs
abundance on Earth and if you're not
just an empty body fighting for New
Earth you're not done on the path you're
just not done if you're not an empty
body fighting for New Earth you're not
done on the path you're not done if it
hasn't if it hasn't been been an obvious
an obvious snap an obvious surrender of
everything that is the lower sense of
self all of that all the hijacker all of
that stuff it's if that's not obviously
completely gone and the water flow is
just channeling of building new Earth
and there's an obvious feeling that the
body itself is just empty and moving
effortlessly in that direction there's
not dness on the path there's been
artificial grounds that have been
created there's all kinds of other
distortions that can be reflected out
until the and purified until the warrior
uh is fully awake alive and building the
new
world so God will effortlessly Roar this
out the body's mouthpiece when the
douche Fu contractor has done sing in
delusion
so more on The Saga of miam so Magdalena
so um she is triggering so many
contractions limits in the spiritual
Community they are going
nuts so um this is my friend uh who I
did that video about on um when Oneness
um collides with the
Matrix um for me The Duality is
refreshing she is appearing as a
catalyst to destroy the spiritual
contraction and Liberate the mouthpiece
from hijacker remnants so water can flow
in various unblocked ways for New Earth
and
so this is very triggering in the
spiritual Community is super triggering
right now because there's there's a lot
of Reflections that are happening about
contracted spiritual [__] that are
sitting and not doing anything for New
Earth they are not honorably dying into
building the new Earth they are sitting
back like little uh spiritual [__] that
are uh just masturbating on Concepts
just fapping on Concepts all day long
and so it's and fapping on not doing
anything there's fapping on on on uh uh
uh inaction fapping on in action in
building the new world just completely
fapping and so it's extremely triggering
in the spiritual Community right now and
I love
that and this is what it looks like and
what it feels like happens when the idea
I can say something wrong is
destroyed unprecedented freedom for the
mouthpiece to flow authenticity so this
is what I was talking about regarding
that contracted dust program in that
open
space balloons in that open space
there's that contracted dust program and
when that Catalyst travels Across The
Ether and can get into that little
pinhole within that dust program it can
[__] explode the contraction of that
dust program and Liberate the mouthpiece
to authentic
flow in service to Earth and service to
God in service to The Highest Potential
here so this is uh many of you know know
I was in India for 3 months earlier this
year when I visited bodgaya where Buddha
was enlightened I spent time with the
dalit kids we are planning on opening a
free school for 150 plus Delite kids
this is your heads up that I'm going to
ask for donors for this soon so you can
see here is you know here's me teaching
at the dalit school this is me with my
friend Vicky this is uh us together
we're we're planning with chica too
we're planning uh and her dog we're
planning on the on on the school this is
our our uh uh this is Vicki's land this
is the blueprint this is a local one of
the local Villages that just got water
system so this is what I'm talking about
regarding basic needs infrastructures
this is what I'm talking about regarding
the warrior dying on its [__] sword
this is what I'm talking about with
building the new Earth it's this kind of
stuff I [__] hate spiritual people
and non-u people that are masturbating
on Concepts all day long equally to as
much as I hate the world economic forum
and the global Elites that and the
bankers that are [__] Contracting
people in Matrix prisons that are then
their own [__] prisoner pris prison
guards in those prisons I [__] hate
the woke culture I [__] hate all of
that [__] all that [__] is a
goddamn distraction from the new Earth
all of it is the game the beautiful game
that God is retardedly playing with
itself and this is the only [__] that
matters basic needs for all is the only
thing that matters Nothing Else Matters
wake up nothing else matters if you were
decentralized and distributed like the
biological systems which you already are
but you're contracted into the illusion
of Separation but if you truly felt that
which is what God's flow is if you truly
felt that what would happen is you
wouldn't care about anything besides
liberating all of your body if you were
actually non-local and omnio across all
bodies you would care about nothing
besides freeing yourself of all of the
contractions in the root systems on the
planet it and that's what's happening is
there's a network which is like the
internet the human bodies are just like
a [__] Network like the internet and
there's all these contractions within
that distributed decentralized system
there's all these contractions and silos
of billionaires and Matrix prisons and
all kinds of [__] so if you were
actually raw selfly self-realized if you
were completely selfless if you if the
god flow was roaring through you and you
were activated in god mode and you could
[__] rap about it and fight about it
and everything then all you would care
about is decentralization of basic needs
and structures and freeing people to be
[__] free for generations to come so
children can be born to be [__] free
to be artist to be creative to wake up
every day and not have to sell their
time for money for Earth to have the
indigenous wisdom of unity and harmony
with nature to be built into its
technological Utopias infrastructures
it's such a joke that these things even
have to be said and that they're not
obvious it's such a joke so [__] you for
pretending like oh that's not obvious to
me yes it is all of that is obvious now
shut the [__] up and go die on that
sword and go build that
[__] this is also getting so [__]
annoying to watch so there's a there's a
uh
on on FR on on Friday Sam Altman was
fired by open ai's board and then he was
hired by Microsoft late Sunday and then
returned to open AI on Tuesday and
then and then I'll I'll read the rest of
it and then I'll get back to that one so
this is an there is an arms race playing
out they're popping
champagne because of the way it was
played the stock price climbed to an
all-time high Shares are now up
58% uh mark market caps at 2.8 trillion
now and investors are excited because of
this desire to gain exposure to Ai and I
wrote it's obvious kayfabe this is all
matrix kayfabe it's not even discreet
anymore it's just blatant it in your
face complete Matrix kayfabe basic needs
are ignored while billionaires
unethically pump [__] your games
elitists we calling you
out and there's a taging of Microsoft
and open Ai and Sam Alman and Saia
nadela and also Elon Musk although Elon
I feel like is tagged here because just
to bring it to the awareness that um
because there because there's many other
aspects that I feel like he feels
aligned for for um basic needs
liberation of Earth and then there's
hashtag Tech AI corruption and find God
because there's no [__] God in this
it's just obvious kayfabe the The Matrix
kayfabe is obvious what do you do it's
just pumping dude it's all pumping this
is an obvious pumping what are we going
to do how how are we going to get media
attention that is fake well we're going
to do kayfabe okay look up kayfabe if
you don't know what kayfabe is look it
up and study it in detail because that's
all the Matrix does is kayab it's a
bunch of [__] [__] kayab and also
influencers are really good at kayfabe
it's all a bunch of [__] lies right
it's staged [__] so this is a staged
[__] where they're like okay we're
going to fire you from the board and
then Microsoft's going to hire you
and and then you're going to return to
open Ai and by the way all the [__]
propagandic media Outlets that are
controlled by the Matrix are going to
dump articles onto the internet about it
so then you have billions of people that
are looking at this that are then pump
pumped pumping Microsoft or open AI with
value and then that's why you get this
goddamn [__] which is that the stock
price climbed to an all-time high the
the it's [__] obvious what's
happening it's obvious what's happening
they're [__] popping champagne
billionaires with their [__] inflated
goddamn egos not giving a [__] at all
about basic needs about the poor in
middle class not caring at all not
caring at all it's just obvious kayab
and it's [__] [__] and the AI
arms race is another [__] excuse to
be selfish and greedy instead of to
decentralize and distribute and be
ethical and be smart and take things in
the direction of finding God godamn find
God you stupid corrupt Matrix Elites
find God allow this Catalyst into the
goddamn little pinhole within that
cancerous program that's running in the
open space and allow your body to be
surrendered to God serving basic needs
for
all gosh ins of us this is a good one
too it's yay it's yay talking about we
as a collective Our God God is inside us
and y's got some such good music you
know he's obviously a goat a greatest of
all time and and
um and and I think that that that just
speaks even more to how um that these
guys are um activated in god mode and
spiritual [__] can learn to uh
obliterate their contractions that hold
them back from being in the same God
mode as these goat
rappers here's another conversation a
friend sent me a screenshot of what I
wrote about if you're not just an empty
body fighting for New Earth you're not
done on the path God will effortlessly
Roar out the body's mouthpiece when the
douche [__] contractors done sing in
delusion and they wrote yes that energy
though and I say yes freedom and fire
transmutation new Earth now it's time
this is a fun thread it's a couple
slides here it's time burn everything
false self rules yes not selfish yes
like dragon spitting fire like collie
chopping off heads the Matrix will fall
heah new world will manifest it is
Purity holism and abundance for all and
then that beautiful face of ah yeah and
with the Earth and love my heart sings
This freedom from the slavery of
separation for women to be safe and free
free to express their gifts for children
to be born free without selling their
time just yes it's beyond words it's
action this is the responsibility of the
Divine masculine is to build new Earth
to Shepherd new Earth for women to be
safe to be free to express their gifts
to be able to nourish and support the
Divine masculine because the masculine
is worshiping the divine feminine and
for children to be born free without
selling their time this is all about the
Seventh Generation principle in
indigenous culture it's all about that
you have to die on The Sword of building
the future of Harmony for all and basic
needs abundance for
all it's beyond words it's action not
budging at all from this etched on the
sword that's always wielded
etched etched you can see it on the
sword right there [__] see it on the
sword it's always etched there that's
new Earth abundance and prosperity for
all and it's always wielded taking a
stand love you I'm with you I love you
too yes as family the new world is done
amen amen so it
is amen so it is good night good night
rest well you know good morning Holy
Communion always now always now never
not holy holy
holy always holy haha life is a typo
holy ha
haha bless bless yes
hugs so
kisses
blessings 2023 and everyone wants to get
rich what's up wealth Maniac but the
best way to get
so this one is funny this is a great
parody if you listen basically this
guyle starting a manure EMP making a
parody on the
swiers as the cancer on the internet
cuz it's totally out of control there's
endless uh uh swindlers and um fake
gurus on the internet that are making
all kinds of [__] um uh courses for
like thousands of dollars for you to
learn how to teach courses to other
people to make money and all kinds of
[__] [__] [__] [__] red
flag red flag red flag red flag red flag
those those course creators that are the
[__] ones that are swindlers they
equally need to be dragged by the
testicles out onto the Warfield for New
Earth and this one's beautiful this is
emerging from 3 days of a dark of
Darkness Retreat and you can see that
there's this re there's this deep
realization that it's always here and
it's impossible to
leave and this is The Greatest Story
Ever Told is you this now and you've
always been held you've always been
loved you've always been
exactly the absolute exactly God exactly
the Indescribable you've never left it
it's not possible to leave it so
sometimes that that Stillness really
helps so much to just grock that and
then go and die into the building the
new
world you must Master a new way of
thinking before you master a new way of
being
so in this case the
breaking every limit [__] YOLO full
life force for the new world because
what you're doing is you're mastering a
new way of thinking which is that um
which is then influencing the being
right so it's God thinking and I I write
it here too that in this next one that
it's always emptiness that's thinking
it's always God that's thinking it's
always the case there's always no one
home and when there's no limits the new
world is is the essence of the flow so
meaning that it's always the case that
the thoughts are God's thoughts and that
the flow but then there's that that that
you we got to give it a word CU selfing
itself needs a word and hijacker is a
really good word for that because it
basically it basically contracts the god
flow into selfishness and greed and
unethical principles and Corruption and
and all kinds of
[__] and so then it's this illusion
that there is someone home and that
there is separation and that there are
limits and that um it doesn't matter
about the new world and so when the
hijacker is completely obliterated
there's just no limits and the the new
world is the essence of the pure God
flow I love this one too this is really
good one for the parents some of us are
raising the Wild Ones the room recers
and reality Checkers the fire tonged and
fierce leaders the wild-hearted and
World Changers is very applicable to my
M my mom and my dad these kids can argue
like a prosecutor when you just wish
they'd say yes Mama and move on but one
day they will use those skills to stand
up for themselves for the people they
love and for perfect strangers because
Injustice doesn't live in their
world so this is really the the essence
of these uh what you whatever you want
to call them these um star seeds Rainbow
Children I don't give a [__] what you
call them um the ones that are just
going completely out of control for for
the new world and they just don't oblig
to any of the Matrix um the new world
Warriors they just don't apply to any of
the Matrix um uh propaganda or or
systems and and they just argue like
crazy to get out of those and to build
the new so those are the those are the
real ones those are the absolute real
ones the ones that live and breathe
non-separation and godf flow for the new
world this one's really good by Jack
kowak also the silence is so intense
that you can hear your own blood Roar in
your ears but Louder Than That by far is
the mysterious Roar which I always
identify with the Roaring of the diamond
wisdom the mysterious Roar of Silence
itself which is a
great
reminding you of something you've seemed
to have forgotten in the stress of your
day since
birth get it get it get it get it I'm
serious this type of stuff dude you got
to be [__] working out my friends you
got to be working
out you got to be working out you got to
be working out you got to be on the ABS
you got to be on the push-ups you got to
be on the squats you got to be on the
Shadow Boxing on the pull-ups you got to
be on all of it you got to be stretching
the body you got to be activating
activating the warrior within and you
got to be doing that multiple times a
day if you're not doing those types of
body weight workouts multiple times a
day you're actually inhibiting the god
flow of the Divine masculine within you
you're inhibiting it you're inhibiting
it you're
[Music]
lethargy uh program is is has got the
body party like it
1776 no for real let's cut these tyrants
out dude this is what I'm saying 250
years ago there's [__] roaring Divine
masculine for [__] these tyrants [__]
this [__] but you see here I wrote
at the bottom that men have been simped
into Call of Duty into Cod which is a
Sim within a Sim it's a simulation
within this Infinity War simulation and
jiggas be playing Cod but can't exit and
build [__] you see it's like you grab
the controller and you're in a
simulation within this simulation and
you're stuck there playing for days and
days and days and days and days and days
meanwhile in the s in the simulation out
out uh outside that in the one in this
one what is is that there's obvious
tyranny that's happening there's totalan
tiptoe totalitarian tiptoe that's
happening and and uh because you can
distract yourself and escape and do all
kinds of [__] uh you don't have to go
into it like these guys did these guys
there was so much a pain in the Tyranny
and there was so little room for
distraction that 1776 there had to be
the independence there had to be getting
the tyrants out of the picture and so
this is the type of action that we're
talking about with the Divine masculine
that steps into its energy to build the
new world to liberate from the tyrannies
of the totalitarian tipt that are
happening and exit and build build the
[__] New World Sovereign homesteads
and communities energy food water Joy
housing all kinds of things make it
abundant make it abundant make it
Sovereign yeah this toxic masculinity
woke [__] [__] hate these woke [__]
would kill them all but I don't have to
because the world economic form is doing
it for us the global Elite are doing it
for us the deprogrammed man all the
deprogrammed man has to do is go and
build the new world just go and build
the new world and keep the sword wielded
and and ready
to
that's the Matrix
tentacles you're you're just making sure
that those Matrix tentacles don't get
anywhere near the families that are
building the new world and whatnot
because all of the ones that are going
to be stuck all these woke [__] are
going to be stuck in The Matrix prisons
and will send them catalysts Through The
Ether in order to try to shatter their
programs and try to ring them into the
the new world but the ones that are
stuck in those patterns the the global
Elites are going to have their own doing
with them because they're going to be
obsoleted they're going to be completely
obsoleted eating all kinds of meat's
going to be illegal they're going to be
um all kinds of centralized Bank digital
currencies limitations on what they can
do there's going to be AI robots and
drones that are taking over all of the
jobs that are enslaving all that kind of
[__] is going to is going to happen it's
part of the dark arts Playbook and it's
part of the trajectory of where things
are going it's impossible for it not for
it not to be that way go look at the
billionaire Matrix kayab we just talked
about they're the exact same programs
that are doing this
nonsense exit and
build when did it become okay I love
this to [__] our sisters then kick them
to the curb and get high-fived by our
brothers I remember when I first started
getting this programming slapped out of
me in
2018 so much
repenting I thank God for the
initiations into worshiping the feminine
now seeing the Demonic force and
eviscerating it like a laser beam is
dojo and I'll uh I'll read the next one
too as it relates to that and when the F
did it become okay to disrespect their
fathers like that and their
mothers and to raise women to sell their
[__] on only fans or [__] away on
Instagram when did it become okay for
men to abandon God's will of basic needs
for all for their selfish
Pursuits this contractive programming
oozed into the hive mind and Collie is
hungry to eat
it it's just such a [__] this this way
that the brothers are high-fiving each
other and also how the women are sleding
away and uh allowing themselves to be
used women are allowing themselves to be
used uh instead of uh becoming the
divine feminine and um and finding the
Divine masculine and then the the not
Divine masculine is just [__] and
kicking women to the curb and then
high-fiving their brothers disrespecting
their fathers disrespecting their
mothers um the father fathers and
mothers did not raise the women to sell
their [__] on only fans or [__] away
on IG but it somehow managed to happen
and that's another part of the Divine
parenting is for that kind of thing for
the for the Divine masculine to come
into the boys so that they don't s and
also so that they don't [__] kick to
the curb or even or even con consider
the the Divinity of being pure until you
identify uh you date and you identify
the one that you want to start family
with and um and the masculine again is
in its selfishness and its greed and it
in its separation and unethical it
abandons God's will of basic needs for
all and it runs the hijacker programs
which is all about selfish
Pursuits and so colie is hungry to eat
all of this that's what the Divine
Warrior masculine is is it's hungry as
[__] to eat all of that contracted
programming that's oozed into the high
mind this one also USA logic so this is
a this is a photo from the inside of an
uh Afghanistan arms dealer and the
weapons are leftover weapons from
America's time in Afghanistan so here's
USA logic you go to war using taxpayer
money against people's will you kill
innocent people and take resource
Supremacy you leave the weapons behind
behind equipping the retaliation you use
more taxpayer money in
counterterrorism you the global Elites
pump the military stocks and the global
bankers and the poor and middle class
eat [__] because the poor and middle
class are the ones that are bearing the
[__] burden as taxpayers onto this
meanwhile the global Elite and bankers
siphon out the wealth with pumping these
military stocks that the poor and middle
class don't agree with they don't agree
with going to war they don't agree with
going
kill in innocent people they don't agree
with the US's tentacles everywhere they
don't agree with and then uh and then
the the equipping the insurgencies and
the retaliations um with the weapons
that are left behind I mean guys this is
the dark arts 101 it's way too [__]
obvious it's way too obvious all all
that has to happen is just stop
pretending like it's not obvious and
just start speaking about it like it is
obvious and then it access catalysts to
cease all of those contracted programs
and to liberate into building the new
world so we're sick of this we're done
with this and we're moving on and just
be [__] clear and constituted as that
repeatedly in all of your conversations
and all of your beingness all the
time and this this last one is you did
not come here to serve fictitious money
in governments you came here to bring
Heaven to Earth
you did not come here to simp to The
Matrix you did not come to simp to The
Matrix okay any facet of the Matrix Big
Daddy governments only fans girls
playing in video game
Loops vax me Daddy uh war war war
propagating War um you did not come here
to simp to the those
programs you came to serve Earth you
came to serve Earth to build new Earth
and that's what all of the body is to be
constituted as as an empty vessel for
God's will to channel through it to
build new earth that is the highest
teaching that is the highest
spirituality that is the highest
everything is that that's it 100%
completely empty of self is 100% in
Union with God that's the end of the
story there's no other way around it
100% empty of self is 100% in Union in
God's Divine flow everything running
through the mouthpiece is for the new
world for decentralization for basic
needs abundance for all for children to
be free for women to be safe to express
their gifts for men to be joyous and
abundant and everyone deserves that
everyone deserves that the next
Generations deserve that it's end of the
story there is no budging from that is
the end of the story it is a done deal
it's already done the new world is
already done we are to come from that
frequency of it being already done and
never budging from it never budge from
it never budge from it that's what
constitutionalization means is never
budge from it new world or bust on the
sword is etched on the sword is New
World Warrior abundance for all
prosperity for all
no Matrix
tentacles none of
them and then just emanating that always
everywhere emanating that being an
inspiration to those that are literally
Desperately Seeking this type of
inspiration you know watching this
content is almost is a is a you know
it's it's it is in a way it's like it's
being baptized into the new world
watching this content is getting
pummeled by catalysts of a constituted
Warrior for new for the new Earth and
therefore then there's a
constitutionalization that can happen on
the receiving end where there's a [__]
this I'm so done with the old I'm so
done with the Matrix enslavement [__]
I'm just 100% constitutionalized as this
empty vessel for God's flow for the new
world I'm done with all my selfing I'm
done with all my hijacker programs I'm
done with being a spiritual [__] I'm
done with all that [__] it is 100%
game over and it is GG it is time to
move forward and build the new Earth
only and to emanate that everywhere that
this body that this mouthpiece moves and
it's done and it's
done and so it
is here we
are Envision the new world the solar
Punk future
complete harmony with Earth complete
harmony with each other basic needs met
for all children frolicking with
excitement and freedom women and men in
Harmony in
Divinity abundant and
free technology being in complete Unison
and harmony with nature and with
humanity and you can hear those birds
chirping you can you can be you can feel
the the animals that are around
also in play with the
humans the
Flora also the planets green ecosystems
coming alive with excitement instead of
being
choked by the human cancer selfish
Tendencies and you can see how from that
place we can be abundant in our space
exploration
also we can become exactly what God has
destined us to
be we can have complete abundance and
prosperity for
all it's already done it's there you're
there you're envisioning it
now this
Galactic this
Universal this free energy
this abundance for all this complete
creative freedom complete harmony with
nature complete saturation into love and
Divinity
constantly it's already there you're
already
there now constitutionalize as that and
never
move and that's how the new world
manifests much love excited to do more
of these
soon thanks for tuning
in and feel free to comment below would
love to hear from you on the
episode And subscribe if you haven't yet
share the episode with people you think
might be interested in it and let's uh
let's do this the new world is
done
you can join the Dow the Link's in the
bio below to join the Dow home da it's a
great way to homestead and build the new
communities there also the patreon links
down there if you want to join in that
way and uh the website's down there with
all the projects you can check that
out support in sharing those if they
excite
you
for